but what has been interesting about TV
encouraged in terms of being
disillusioned or not is that it is a
completely different medium because your
role as a director is a completely
different one like it shouldn't even be
called the same they should make up a
new word I think for because in a movie
in a feature film you create the world
from scratch why don't you cast your
people you did make every decision
costumes the locations all of that from
scratch you work on the script you put
your team together you are responsible
for everything and you know not that all
every idea is yours but you are the
filter through which everyone else's
ideas are filtered and you as the
director are the one that goes yes no
yes yes no you know in TV you come on
board with a script that the DGA says
you need to have 24 hours before
principal photography so sometimes you
get a script as you get on the plane you
read the script on the plane it's very
clear because the script is already such
a political document because it's been
in development with the network with a
production company with the showrunner
with them of Finance years that this is
already the compromised document that
everyone agreed on the last thing they
want is your opinion about anything as a
director it's very clear direct what's
on the page so that's the first
difference then the actors are already
cast all the sets are already built in
the studio they already are wearing what
they have been wearing for the last
couple of episodes in a future film you
are the one that knows most about the
story and knows most about the world
it's set in and that is where you get
all your authority and strength from you
don't have to pull the director card
because you have substance because you
have set with a story for so long in TV
it's the exact opposite you know less
about everything than anyone else who is
there and who has worked on all the
other episodes right and everybody knows
that including the actors and the
showrunner which I wasn't even clear on
the concept when I did my first episode
that there is a show runner who has
overseen the writing concept and is the
authority on
set and who is actually making the
decisions it's not you as the director
because at first I was always like
should I make that decision you know
we're at production meetings we're in a
feature film environment you would get
asked thousand questions from all the
department heads and suddenly I was in a
production meeting for TV where I wasn't
asked a single question I was more like
added I was auditing the production
meeting more than anything and then
there is another thing at TV which is
called the tone meeting which I also
wasn't familiar with I saw on the
schedule tonight tone meeting so I
showed up for the tone meeting I was
like I wonder what that should I prepare
something what is it it's basically
where the writers sit you down and go
through the script scene by scene and
explain to you what is important about
every scene and what they need you to
deliver and they will tell you about
every actors weaknesses and strengths
and about you know be careful that that
doesn't happen here too and you
basically take notes and then you go and
set and you try to deliver that and at
first it was a real kind of switch that
you had to make in your creative ego
because you were so used I was so used
to being the creative authority on set
and at least have the last word
not with a budget obviously if
something's out outside of the budget
the producer will have the last word and
very quickly tell you what you can or
can't do but within the creative process
I was the one who got to make the
decisions with TV it's more like you are
an advisor who can voice a suggestion
but whether that is being done depends
on if it faults on you know fruitful
ground or not with a showrunner with the
actors and because the actors are very
aware that you are not the authority
they have no problem saying like no I
won't do that
and so you are in a position where you
can't plan very much because you can
only in a movie you can plan because you
can count on the people that you cast
making a concerted effort to execute
what you're trying to do in TV there
might be one or two people that just
know their character better and they
protect that character which I
completely understand because they are
dealing with a different director every
week and if they completely did what
every director wanted the show wouldn't
have any continuity and consistency so
they have to protect that but that also
means if I go in with a rigid plan I
will just hit a wall and that'll be the
end of it you know so after I got
through that first shock where was like
what am I actually because I want to be
a good director I've been hired I want
to do my job I want to be worth the
money they're paying me what do I
actually do if I came to set I did the
blocking that's the one thing you get to
do as a TV director you get to suggest
where everyone should stand and where
everyone should move if I drop dead
after that I don't think anyone would
notice until the end of the day if
someone else called action every note
that it's amazing but that was the
disillusion said a work delusion
disillusion with with the process
illusion yeah
or you're like this is not the creative
process I went to film school for and I
kind of want to put a bullet in my head
right now
but then I realized that it's the
greatest film school you could ever go
through because you have to deliver
something within a world that has been
created and it's like this training
exercise because you have to understand
what that world is what the rules of
that world are what the tone of that
world is and you have almost no time to
understand how every actor works because
with a movie you have rehearsal time
that you you know you have much more
time to warm up with people
whereas in TV you have minutes before
you are shooting your first take and
then you have one or two takes and then
you have to move on in a movie you do
like Fincher 40 takes you know there's
always something interesting here the
actors have prepared their performance
which been a movie doesn't happen I
think in a movie the movie actor prides
himself or herself to come to set as a
blank slate you know and then just try
stuff and you put your heads together
and the joy is to experiment and find
things to
in TV you don't have that cause you
don't have the time you are shooting a
45 minute episode in six days there is
no time for experimentation so they come
with a with a performance that they have
thought out in their hotel rooms and
they show it to you and you get one
tweak maybe two and if you want more
than that everything comes to a
standstill
and there's this atmosphere something's
wrong you know we're out of sync
or something and everyone gets insecure
and the showrunner comes in and makes
the decision
so I kind of quickly had to learn that
it's a completely different rhythm you
know and the problem is that by the time
that you have earned your actors trust
and I get that that's a very valid
process for them to go through the shoot
is over like on every episode where I
have six days by day six
I have the feeling now we all trust each
other we know what we're capable of and
now we could go off and make a movie
together or make an episode together or
whatever the problem is that we just
made the episode clear a while that
wasn't necessary okay so it's a great
it's a great environment to try your own
directing abilities because you have to
be fast and you get to try a lot of
stuff and if stuff goes wrong you don't
feel quite as connected to the final
creative outcome as you would in a movie
that you have been working on for two
years so it gives you a certain freedom
with the movie if I Drive to set in the
morning I'm nauseous
because I'm so nervous because
everything if anything doesn't work out
that day then it's on me you know where
it's been been TV the Machine is already
running someone had this great analogy
actually the showrunner of the first
show that I did he said in movies you
hold the steering wheel like this tight
you know and with the TV show it's more
this where you kind of gingerly cut off
yeah and that's exactly what it is and
it's like to stay with the car analogy
it's like the movie is like a stick
shift I think where if you don't press
the gas that will just stay and nothing
will happen whereas with an automatic if
you don't do anything
that kind of slowly drives anyway and
that is what the TV show is I think a TV
show could direct itself without a
director probably and would more or less
look the same whereas a movie will just
fall apart if there weren't a director
and that took a little bit to learn but
by now I'm having a lot of fun doing TV
exactly because of these limitations
because every it's so fast you're in and
out you know it's as if you are getting
into the six day training camp with
people you don't know with a team you've
never worked together with Lucy much
harder for you no idea what his style is
do you have very little time to learn
what he's been doing with the other
seasons the other episode and you have
to work within that environment and
adjusting to that is it I think a really
good exercise I think it's made me a
much better director whenever I get to
make my next feature film I think TV you
would have been a good exercise and
training camp
you